balls pyramid off the coast of Australia
is what's left of an old volcano that
emerged from the sea about seven million
years ago and for years this place had a
secret about 20 kilometres from the
spindle of rock there's a bigger island
called Lord Howe Island here there used
to be an insect famous for being big it
was a stick insect as big as a human
hand and nicknamed a tree lobster then
one day in 1918 a supply ship ran
aground at Lord Howe Island and while it
was being repaired some rats managed to
get from the ship to the island where
they instantly discovered that giant
stick insects are a delicious rat food
two years later the rats were everywhere
and the tree lobsters were totally gone
declared extinct in the 1960s some
climbers on ball's pyramid thought they
might have seen some stick insect
corpses on the rocks but the species was
nocturnal and no one wanted to scale the
spire hunting for bugs in the dark that
was until 2001 when two scientists
decided to take a closer look from the
water they had seen a few patches of
vegetation that might support the
insects so they boated over swimming
would have been much easier but there
were too many sharks hanging on the
vertical rock surface they found a
single small spindly Bush and underneath
that Bush they found something totally
improbable hiding there spread out on
the bushy surface were enormous shiny
black bugs 24 in all these were the only
ones on balls perma'd the last ones they
live here and as best we know nowhere
else how they got there we still don't
know perhaps they hitchhiked on birds or
traveled over on a boat how they
survived for so long on just a single
patch of plants
nobody knows either it was thought that
the next step should be to get a few of
these insects into a protected breeding
program
but the Australian government wasn't so
keen after two years of meetings and
studies they finally agreed to allow
just for animals to be retrieved during
those two years there had been a
rockslide on the mountain and it was
feared that the whole population had
been wiped out
fortunately the insects again showed
their survival skills and were found
still nestled around their bush one pair
collected were named Adam and Eve and
taken to the Melbourne Zoo Adam and Eve
the reluctant travellers first to leave
the safety of their mothership shrub in
80 years could ultimately return their
whole species to their former home but
Lord Howe Island is still rampant with
rats and whilst residents might be happy
to go rat free they might not be so sold
on the idea of doing it to allow an army
of hardshell dry and crawling insects to
move in it's an incredible illustration
of man's impact both in the presumed
extinction of and the possible
preservation of this unique insect its
main attraction is that it has lived on
the planet for a long time and we have
the power to keep it around I don't know
if it will work but in the end that's
the stick insects best argument